mais influent
avant de commencer à vous raconter un
peu mes histoires de voyages elles sont
un peu bas revente je vous disais
maintenant on va faire un petit exercice
et je vous demandais de me faire
confiance parce qu'on va tous je vous
demandais de fermer les yeux et de
suivre un peu ce que je vais vous
demander de faire aller je m'assurer que
tout le monde a fermé les yeux
tout le monde ferme les yeux parfait pas
des tricheurs
alors ce que je vais vous demander de
faire en fait c'est de respirer pendant
5 secondes
on va les faire 5 respiration on va
respirer d'une manière assez
particulière on va respirer profondément
ou pas ou par la bouche ou par le nez va
mettre toute notre volonté dans
l'inspiration et la respiration et
d'expiration ça va être un lâcher prise
on va faire d'une manière continue sans
arrêt pendant cinq fois donc suivi un
peu potentiellement le rythme de ma
respiration
allez go on va faire tous ensemble en
union s'il vous plaît
parfait ça fait 5
merci infiniment j'étais bien fait
relaxer un peu ça on n'est plus obligé
d'attendre quelque chose qui va se
passer en fait on est ce qu'on a fait en
fin de ces justes de se mettre tous
ensemble dans le moment présent on a
essayé 505 respiration n'est
potentiellement pas suffisant mais voilà
c'est un début ça nous a permis aussi
d'être sur un même niveau on s'est mis
tout sera menée dans une seule
expérience est ce que je vais essayer
aussi de faire à travers cette
présentation que j'ai nommé un voyage
autour de soins et j'ai utilisé cette
citation d'alan watts qui dit être de
passage c'est vivre en fait je vais te
manquer parce que la suite veut dire
enfin la suite d'y rester et se
maintenir c'est mourir mais comme
j'avais déjà parlé de la vitesse de la
mort donc j'ai enlevé cette partie
sachant que j'ai pas vu sa présentation
donc voilà l'idée en fait de ce voyage
que j'avais entrepris à est à peu près
deux ans et demi trois ans c'était en
juin 2014 était venue d'une d'une
intuition va dire en fait je vais parler
du pouvoir de la décision un peu de
cette histoire de voyage comment ça a
commencé un jour alors que j'étais
toujours employé dans une multinationale
ingénieur en informatique project
manager rejeté prêts et d'en contrôler
je suis en train de conduire ce pour
rentrer chez moi et puis soudain une
idée une intuition qui passe mais
vraiment une voix dans ma tête qui me
dit tu vas faire le tour du monde et là
j'étais sur la route je me gare
tellement d'idées été foudroyante
tellement c'était puissant
je me gare et puis je me dis mais qu'est
ce qui se passe je descends le
rétroviseur je me regarde dans les yeux
et je pose la question est ce que tu es
sérieuse et la réponse que je vois dans
mes propres yeux étaient été oui et ça a
commencé à partir de ce point là c'était
en septembre 2013
deux semaines après j'avais je déposerai
ma demande d'année sabbatique auprès de
mon boulot rien ne prédestinait en fait
à voyager je vous mentirais si je vous
disais c'est un truc un rêve d'enfant je
voulais toujours faire ça je vais
toujours partir à la découverte du monde
absolument pas j'étais complètement dans
l'ambition je voulais réussir ma vie
mais vraiment professionnel c'est tout
ce qui apporte est pour moi la vie
sociale professionnelle je voulais être
riche à voir mais mon appart ma voiture
etc etc
et puis cette pensée tellement puissante
qui arrivent d'un coup et je la prends
tout simplement comme étant une décision
personnelle quelque chose qu'est ce qui
s'est passé dans ma tête à ce moment là
qu'ils y c'est moi qui ai décidé en fait
c'est pas une voix ce n'est pas une
révélation
j'avais fait cette décision mais sont
potentiellement l'avoir ramené à ma
conscience jusqu'à ce moment là où il
s'est imposé tout naturellement et à
partir de ce moment là en fait tous et
toutes des commencé d'une manière
complètement naturel je faisais ma
demande d'année sabbatique
on a dit oui au boulot donc pour
m'accorder carrément une année ce qui
est un fait assez rare au maroc on va
dire et j'avais pas le rang mais tous
ces faits d'une manière complètement
naturel mon père qui est dans la sai
m'avait dit non mais t'es folle tout
simplement été un peu barge pour pour
avoir ce genre d'idées et puis par la
suite lui aussi au bout de deux mois et
r'way super vas-y je vais y aller avec
toi et voilà ça c'est fait au bout de
neuf mois j'étais sur le départ je suis
parti je suis parti en juin 2014
au départ du nicaragua pourquoi
nicaragua s'est un peu et ouais alors
pourquoi nicaragua mais c'est encore une
histoire de un peu un peu barge en même
temps alors alors que je préparais ce
voyage là d'une année une année vraiment
excellent et ça se prépare longuement
j'avais fait plusieurs options des
fichiers excel super détaillé c'était
mon boulot en fait je faisais que ça des
fichiers excel pour faire des projets et
ses terrains donc j'ai fait
potentiellement 15 options de trajet
vraiment avec la météo qu'il faut le
budget etc etc
depuis un certain moment je me suis dit
mais attends un peu tu veux prendre une
année en dehors du temps une année au
demandeur de ta vie donc tu vas faire
quelque chose qui complètement en dehors
de la zone de confiance oublie le
project management oublier le contrôle
on va faire quelque chose de
complètement différent va partir sur un
os plein plein
et le nom plein plein en fait c'était
très simple j'ai tout simplement
supprimer tous les fichiers excel et
j'aurais ouvert google maps je regardais
le premier pays je savais que je voulais
partir je voulais commencer à la mecque
du sud et j'ai regardé le premier pays
c'était le nicaragua et c'est de là que
j'ai commencé
mais en même temps dans cette réflexion
de je ne veux pas partir avec un plomb
je veux partir complètement en dehors de
ma zone de confort j'ai pris le temps de
réfléchir à mon peuple
mon objectif pourquoi j'ai envie
d'entreprendre un an de voyages pourquoi
j'ai envie vraiment de partir c'est dans
cette aventure et je m'étais découverte
en fait une passion du moment où fait
danser mois de préparation qui est elle
à l'harmonica gh1 harmonica j'étais en
train de souffler dans tout le temps en
train de créer du bruit
jusqu'au moment où j'ai compris ah non
en fait c'était pas l'harmonie casser
l'harmonie que j'étais en train de
chercher et donc justement tout mon
voyage était à la recherche de
l'harmonie ramener une certaine harmonie
dans ma vie et au final quand j'ai fait
le tour j'ai compris que ramener cette
harmonie c'est pas une recherche active
en soit c'est vraiment juste d'arrêter
de faire des choses vraiment juste
embrassés l'harmonie naturelle du monde
de la nature des relations humaines etc
les membracides d'une manière
complètement naturel arrêtez de mettre
des blocages moi-même pour pouvoir tout
simplement retrouver cette harmonie au
quotidien tous les jours mais d'abord
avant d'arriver à ce moment là où j'ai
compris ce que c'était que l'harmonie
pour moi il me fallait traverser
plusieurs étapes dans ce voyage là est
une des premières étapes c'était de
commencer à voir et à écouter avec le
coeur il fallait arrêter de voir avec
les datas fallait arrêter que je que
j'analyse que j'essaie de tout
comprendre de programmer les choses donc
je me suis lancé dans cette aventure
complètement aveugle où je voulais que
que donner de l'amour et de le recevoir
donc j'essaie de tout voir avec le coeur
et une des premières expériences qui
m'avait complètement mise par terre en
fait par rapport à cette histoire de
voir avec le coeur c'était en arrivant
en colombie au bout de deux mois de
voyage colombie un pays qui est sur le
papier super dangereux pas très
recommandé pour une
une femme de voyager tout seul dans ce
pays au final je suis resté deux mois et
demi et un certain moment j'étais
j'avais décidé de partir dans un coin
qui s'appelle tanio crise thales la
rivière ou cinq couleurs c'est la plus
belle rivière romande c'est une rivière
vraiment avec des plantes qui ont en
différentes couleurs etc
donc on peut lorsque vous voyez en fait
vous voyez du rouge mais le rouge c'est
c'est la couleur de la plante et cet
endroit l'un est l endroit le plus
dangereux encore longue
c'était une zone rouge ou verte pour les
touristes depuis juste 4 4 qu'apprend
avant avant ce moment où j allais est
complètement contrôlé par l'armée les
farc est les narcotrafiquants bref
c'était le bordel absolue j'arrive quand
même je prends un billet d'avion sans
aucun plan
je débarque c'est une piste
d'atterrissage et pas d'aéroport en
reçoit sans sac vraiment dans la rue la
rue pas de goudron et pas de voiture
juste des motos et les chevaux mais j'y
vais quand même sens tous les a priori
tout ce que j'ai dû sur les médias etc
je me dis ok je vais pas voir ça y est
quelque chose qui m'appelle dans ce coin
là et je vais aller chercher travers le
coeur et donc quand je sors une dame
s'approche de moi et me pose la question
est ce que tu sais où dormir je lui dis
non mehdi ben écoute je t'offre un une
chambre chez moi à 10 dollars la nuit on
dira je fais oui d'accord bien sûr
deux heures après j'étais derrière son
fils en train de faire du motocross dans
la dans les collines de la région donc
la grande aventure
j'ai passé six jours chez cette famille
las il était devenu quelques par ma
famille tout le village était devenu ma
famille aujourd'hui âgé j'avais écrit un
article à l'époque et aujourd'hui des
gens du monde entier qui m'écrivent pour
me poser des questions par rapport à
peigne au christ à l'aise parce que des
voyageurs indépendants qui y vivent et y
en a pas des masses
si vous chercher qu'à new christs aller
sur internet de lyme trouver en premier
est en fait en partant de ce bled là
j'ai pleuré j'ai pleuré à l'aéroport
quand la famille m'avaient accompagné
j'ai pleuré comme lorsque j'ai pleuré le
jour j'ai quitté ma famille ici au maroc
en sachant que j'allais pas les voir
pendant un an et en fait je suis
reconnaissante à cette intuition as eu
cette envie de voir juste avec le coeur
donner complètement juste avec avec des
sensations pures d'amour pour les autres
sans sembler a priori sur comment
issenlor culture etc
un certain moment tout ce tout disparaît
le fait qu'ils parlaient espagnol et que
moi je débutais à peine que je
comprenais juste quelques mois ne
signifie pas ne signifie absolument rien
et une fusion qui s'est fait parce que
ce qui vient du coeur par directement au
coeur il n'a pas besoin vraiment de
langage différent mais alors la sphère
en fait partir avec cette voix du coeur
c'est aussi faire confiance c'est faire
confiance à l'univers en d'humains mais
surtout en soi même et faire confiance
c'est surtout être complètement
vulnérable complètement à la merci des
autres vraiment euros on pourrait pas le
croire aussi aussi facilement plaisir
mais je vais me mettre tout seul quelque
part loin de chez moi loin de mes
repères mais en étant complètement
vulnérable
c'est vraiment ce qui peut vous sauver
c'est vraiment ce qu'il ya rassure ou
assure votre sécurité
j'ai mis ici une photo d'eux que j'avais
prise sur un des fleuves de d'amazonie
au brésil et j'avais fait plusieurs
semaines en amazonie en bateau
traditionnel des petits bateaux vous
voyez là et ces bateaux là il n'avait
pas d'horaires donc qu'ils arrivaient
dans des ports assez pour un c'est
qu'ils craignent vraiment très tard dans
la nuit et à chaque fois je partais bien
sûr sans plan sans aucune idée où ce que
je vais dormir qu'est ce que je vais
faire par la suite c'était un peu mon ma
manière de voyager à chaque fois il y
avait quelqu'un qui se présentait donc
une fois par exemple j'arrivais dans
l'état où il ya le village de mazagan et
j'arrivais à 3 heures du matin et il est
juste une fille qui étaient dans le
bateau qui se présente et qui me pose la
question est ce que tu sais où est ce
que tu vas je lui dit non mais suivant
ne me parlent même pas en parce qu'elle
parlait français par les anglais et
c'était une fille de cet état là il me
dit ne me parle pas parce que les autres
ils devraient pas nous entendre parler
dans une autre langue
on va s'en sortir ensemble est vraiment
le front par la main on a voyagé dans un
taxi pendant
une demi heure pour arriver vraiment au
premier village habitable et c est là
carrément elle va négocier l'hôtel où je
vais dormir et s'assure j'ai fait mon
enregistrement immédiat tout va bien je
dis oui tout va bien elle fait très bien
beau nier revoir je ne connais pas son
prénom je ne sais absolument rien d'elle
cette fille là m'a pris vraiment par la
main est ce qu'il a vraiment existé des
fois je me pose la question
et j'en ai eu des histoires mais plein
comme ça un plein de gens ou au moment
où je suis complètement vulnérable
vraiment à la merci de la première
personne venu parce que je fais
confiance en moi même en l'univers il se
présente toujours un humain qui va me
prendre par la main et m'a mené vraiment
au bon endroit mais cette confiance là
bien sûr et vient avec un sens de la
responsabilité
ça veut dire que ça se passe pas
toujours très bien il ya eu des moments
où je craignais vraiment pour ma vie et
ça s'est passé par exemple je vais
raconter une histoire qui s'est passée
dans le désert bolivien au fin fond
enfin c'est un désert l'altiplano du sud
lipez qui qui se trouve à 4000 mètres
d'altitude fait super froid
y'a pas un arbre à l'horizon et un seul
arbre qui s'appelle l'arbre de la roche
en fait que vous voyez sur la photo est
dans ce désert l'un je traverse la
frontière qui viennent pour aller à la
frontière chilienne entre les deux il ya
70 km/ha no-man's land qui appartient à
personne dans la frontière chilienne on
vit à caen visa a expiré on va devoir de
ramener à la frontière bolivienne en
plein après midi
je le redis miscevic je crains pour ma
vie si vous me renvoyez l'abm 18 ans et
je suis écouté ce qu'il y'a pas moyen
que je dorme ici la nuit que le
lendemain je dorme pas que je dorme
devant la frontière et que je reparte le
lendemain musulmans au caire envoyez moi
en argentine
non bon ok dernier recours données -
téléphone pour appeler l'ambassade
marocain au chili pour les informer et
leur dire que j'étais la personne ne
savait où j'étais y avait pas d'internet
y avait pas de communication ma famille
mes amis personne ne savait où j'étais
mais sinon on va être envoyé dans le
désert bolivien et le désert bolivien
c'est un désert le les plus connus pour
les disparitions et au fait tout dernier
moment où dernier non quand on me dit
non pour pour la peine je
attend il quelque chose de bizarre qui
se passe là ça veut pas être vrai ça ne
peut pas être sympa être une réalité en
fait c'est c'est trop de noms pour ça
soit vrai je suis en train probablement
de créer ma propre expérience et c'est
là que j'ai compris le pouvoir qu'on a
vraiment dans la création de sons de son
expérience de vie en général et je me
suis rendu compte que j'ai tout fait
pour être vraiment là bas en ce moment
là pour être dans cette situation là et
la situation aller en s'empirant et moi
j'allais en me disant en prenant la
responsabilité de tout ce qui se passait
je suis revenu à la frontière bolivienne
et g j'ai survécu à une tentative de
viol il y avait le gars qui avait tenté
et ensuite j'ai pris mon sac et je suis
parti je suis parti rapidement bon bref
j'ai survécu à toutes ces expériences là
mais toujours justement en prenant la
responsabilité alors mais tout ça vient
avec b l'indepa plein de petites choses
que j'ai essayé de faire pendant ce
voyage là j'ai essayé de m'offrir le
présent vivre au présent un maximum ne
pas penser cette expérience est arrivé
et j'ai oublié je laissé derrière moi je
me suis dit ok je prends de
l'apprentissage je vais le vivre tout le
temps au présent j'ai ici également
d'embrasser la liberté la vraie liberté
pour moi je l'aï découvert à cuba où
c'était juste l'acceptation arrêter de
vouloir créer des choses arrêter de
vouloir aller au delà de mes limites
non juste accepter ma réalité telle
qu'elle est l'accepter dans la
compassion d'abord et l'amour pour moi
même et puis un certain moment il me
fallait m'arrêter et je me suis arrêté
pendant huit mois dans un temple au
brésil enfin au bout d'une année de
voyage me suis arrêté pendant huit mois
pour pouvoir enfin arrêter de voyager
dans le physique ce que j'ai voyagé dans
le temps
mon temps est devenu vraiment le moment
présent et très réduit je continue à
voyager dans le physique puis un certain
ans - il fallait arrêter tout je voulais
arrêter de voyager dans le temps et dans
le
dans l'espace pour pouvoir voyager dans
vos dimensions qui sont moi même qui est
à l'intérieur de moi même et et dans
cette expérience là j'ai eu des
expériences mystiques assez assez
intéressante qui ont quelque part à
boudy le temps et l'espace
ensuite en rentrant au maroc il ya cinq
mois
je suis parti faire le chemin de
compostelle en un élan de gratitude pour
l'univers pour tout ce qu'il m'a donné
mais aussi gratitude pour moi même et
c'est ce qui me sauve aujourd'hui c'est
ce qui me continue de me maintenir dans
un état d'esprit heureux malgré toutes
les situations parler par lesquels je
passe je passe par des situations assez
difficile actuellement
mais cette gratitude envers moi même
envers le monde c'est ce qui me permet
en fait de continuer et puis
potentiellement j'ai découvert un peu ce
que c'était que le soin le soin d autre
qu une perception différente du monde
j'ai arrêté d'être réellement petits
soins moi même oudin pour essayer de
venir à travers des expériences
rencontrèrent l'amour que j'ai pour les
autres
quelque chose de beaucoup plus grands
qui ne dépend plus de boudin quelque
chose qui est encore plus grand qui est
l'univers qui est cette relation qu'on a
eus qui ce moment là qu'on a eu au début
de cette rencontre
ce moment de respiration on se rejoint
tous dans une seule action dans une
seule volonté
et puis pour finir ce que vous voyez là
cette photo là c'est la photo de madame
ça c'est le drapeau du maroc devant le
cimetière du village de matador très
loin dans la jungle amazonienne et au
fait qui ce qui est intéressant dans ce
voyage là je pose la question attend
vraiment besoin de voyager
je veux dire que non parce que je suis
parti très long pour retrouver quelque
part cet attachement que j'avais pour
mes sources
pour ma ville d'el jadida parce que je
suis parti en étant je voulais un peu
d'air je voulais respirer de l'air de la
liberté puis je suis parti très loin
pour retrouver quelqu'un devant moi qui
dans les les
les ancêtres à équiper cette ville il ya
plus de 200 ans qui me regardait avec
des yeux d'émotion de dix ans que tu
connais el-jadida je leur disais il me
disait mais parlez nous de cette ville
je suis partie parler des dieux vivants
mais vraiment très très très loin et
mais ma réponse aussi à cette question
est oui il faut voyager faut absolument
voyager en soi même on n'a pas besoin de
faire le voyage physique il faut
vraiment faire autant qu'on peut ce
voyage à l'intérieur de soi même et donc
tout le monde ici est à sa place
parfaitement à sa place
tant qu'on peut quelque part transcender
c'est tous les blocages qu'on a par
rapport au temps par rapport au passé au
futur ce qu'on avait envie qu'on a et c
est ça arrête un moment respirer saisir
ok je prends 5 secondes pour faire un
petit voyage mais vraiment à l'intérieur
de moi même est découvert et découvrir
qui je suis réellement merci
[Applaudissements]